so we have 78 eggs six sticks of butter
I have never whipped this many egg
whites and hit this is like when you're
swimming and you're doing breaststroke
my hand feels like it's literally in a
cloud there we go
this one's for all the money's
[Music]
hi my name is Alvin I'm a tasty producer
and I love making giant food for other
people today I'll be bringing in my
friend jasmine who is a host on bring
these giant food time or she is
surprising her friends with giant foods
at restaurants I want to return the
favor and also see anything that I can
make will stack up against all the
amazing and huge things that she's
gotten to eat so let's go meet her good
how are you good are you hungry
I'm hungry and excited so for the people
that don't know you what do you exactly
do I am also very familiar with giant
food I surprise my friends with giant
foods but I take them to locations that
already serve them and then I invite my
friends in and I make their dreams come
true
so basically you do the exact same thing
that I do except for you go to a
restaurant yeah instead yeah I don't
have to do any other work sounds pretty
darn if you were to request me to make
you any giant version of any food ever
what would you like okay I'm actually
sweating just thinking about it
so I saw a video on tasty about a jiggly
cheesecake why are you laughing I made
that video okay perfect why are you such
a big Japanese jiggly cheesecake fan
it's just this golden-brown beauty you
know and then you take it out of the
oven and it's like steaming and you
jiggle it it jiggles as much as my belly
jiggles just like that I will not bring
you the giant cheesecake unless it
jiggles this is something that I think
is gonna be pretty fun I've made a
recipe for this before and I think we
should just try to make a pretty large
version of it so the first thing we're
gonna do we're just gonna make a liquid
batter and that involves six sticks of
butter so not a diet food sorry just
gonna hook down and then
you can't have a cheese cake without
cream cheese oh man to the pudding cream
cheese island and we're gonna pour in
the milk and whisk it and I think that's
gonna emulsify it and make it smoother
all right the one hand constraining
technique alright this just makes sure
that there is not too many lumps because
I know who is dealing with a lot of
cream cheese and a lot of butters - the
liquids we're gonna add the dry
ingredients so this is just flour Oh
got some cornstarch pretty intense
battery got no matter how many times I
make giant food I always forget how much
of a physical effort it's it's uh again
smooth is quite nice the entire alright
I'm gonna say that this batter is pretty
good pretty smooth I'm gonna set this
aside I wanna take a break whoa this is
heavy there's this pan okay so this is
fun well this is actually the same pan
that I had used for the original recipe
video but I'm sorry it will not be big
enough today so the pan that I'm
actually gonna be using this one over
here this is a hotel pan they use these
pants to serve like food at the face
found what I needed I hope this is gonna
work and I hope I'm in better so I'm
gonna go and start whipping some eggs we
have our pan and the thing is we don't
want our cheesecake to stick so before
we beat any eggs I'm gonna line this pan
with parchment paper
ah
shape these up right now okay so we have
essentially all the pieces we need to
make this cheesecakes parchment lining
work so we're gonna spray it and get
everything to stick together okay so we
got our pan that's lined all right let's
crack some eggs so we have a 78 eggs
because the secret to this recipe is
just a lot of egg whites that's what
makes it so fluffy and we just need to
separate them into whites and yolks so I
was lucky enough to be able to go to
Japan to work with our tasty Japan team
I also went with 3/8 essentially when we
were planning our trip we were like
looking for videos on what to do and we
saw this like crazy
jiggly's Japanese cheesecake so we
actually went to the destination in the
video and in Japan a lot of their
restaurants and shops have glass doors
or glass windows but I wanted to figure
out how the heck they made this recipe
so I did was I was like hey Rhea
can you stand in front of that last
window over there and I was like yeah
just pose a little bit really thought
she was just like you know getting some
nice pictures at the shop and pointing
at things and I was like yeah yeah yeah
any what I was actually doing and I
wasn't taking pictures at all no I was
taking video actually of what was going
on behind Rea and I was essentially
trying to get as close as I could to see
what ingredients they were putting into
the batter
so she was there just you know really
nice didn't suspect to fish well I was
going full mission impossible incognito
essentially came back home to New York
and was like I need to figure out how to
make this cheesecake so I took a guess
at what ingredients they put in so I
would make a batch I would make the
batter
every attempt was two hours I would take
it out and then the real test was once I
took it out I would slap it a cold times
and if it jiggled it worked if it didn't
jiggle it was back to the drawing board
so I went through like 200 eggs for like
12 attempts and
I think I just you know randomly did
some research one night and drastically
changed the ratio of egg whites to egg
yolks and then after like 30 minutes in
the oven I was looking at and I was like
hey it was like blowing up like going
through puberty
I like set the Cheesecake down jiggle I
was like watch anyway like that's the
jiggle big cheese kick right there and
that is the story I'm gonna keep
cracking these eggs I'm gonna be an
expert at separating and cracking eggs
after this all right so we have 12 eggs
left
uh-hum we've done 66 so far and because
we need 12 egg yolks for the actual
batter itself I want to say 12 in here
and then give these back to the kitchen
once I'm done it's time to win oh wait I
mean huh oh god the way hold on separate
the egg whites first yeah this bowl is
not getting big enough I'm gonna split
it into this bowl so I'm gonna eyeball
around 1/2 mmm delicious all right cool
now it's actually time to whip so I'm
gonna get these back in here 1 2 I have
never whipped this many egg whites into
light
there we go how'd I get a wider stick to
stabilize myself this is like when
you're swimming and you're doing
breaststroke
I don't know if you guys can tell but
sort of a brief kind of happy
all right there get into kind of fluffy
I want to take a break we're gonna stop
for now I want to sprinkle in some sugar
I'm so tired
okay this one's getting some sugar all
right this guy get some sugar too
everybody get some sugar so the sugar
acts as a stabilizer as well for the egg
whites framing for soft peaks here was
we want this to be a fluffy cheesecake
actually getting light petkin honey some
oxygen whoa
I'm really lightheaded right now we need
some help let's just could I get some
help I'm about a blackout it's not very
lightheaded could you help me do that
one well I do this one I mean I feel
like we're almost there
we're almost there I just don't want to
collapse hmm okay
yeah okay I'm into it I think this is
good let's do it
that's really so key thank you so much
for your help without that I'd be on the
floor right now but thank you I
appreciate it I'll need it I'm gonna
fold these into the batter we made
earlier and to be honest I don't think
there's a utensil large enough to fold
these into the egg whites so I might
have to use my arms are you gonna throw
me wash my arms never what I think I'd
be using my purse as cooking utensils
what all right arms are washed I'm gonna
fold the egg whites into the batter but
first we got to take these 12 egg yolks
and mix them back into the OD better
these boys are going in add some fat and
texture to this so feeling gold quick
because egg whites in the plate
superfast whoo
all right this batter is ready to be
folded into the egg whites so we're
gonna scoop some mankiewicz oh my god
this is so fun already we're just going
to fold trying to keep this is sanitary
as possible so it's already getting a
little lighter my hand feels like it's
literally in a cloud we're gonna get the
rest of these Oh me here we go this is
why so I'm gonna say that this is good
for the batter I was fun
I'll wash my hands we're gonna pour this
batter into the pan and cross our
fingers to hope that it does stay
exactly the same way that we want it to
and let's do it to actually bake this
thing in the old video I did a water
bath so we're gonna try to replicate
that because I think that helps the
Cheesecake cook a lot more evenly I got
a little like a setup here I'm gonna do
like an inch or so of water not too much
we don't want it to actually touch the
bottom of the pan
so we're gonna put like a little filter
back
and then probably one of my favorite
parts putting the batter into the pan
there we go
[Music]
wait that's awesome I'm going to put
this on top or the water grab this okay
and then smooth it out with an offset
spatula to make sure everything is okay
you know get rid of any of the really
really big air bubbles all right
this is jiggly cheesecake batter there's
a lot of it
I want a very careful take this into the
oven why is this so heavy it's just egg
whites so from my previous recollection
of the original Japanese jiggly
cheesecake it's basically a giant
souffle so there is like no time to
waste the moment it comes out of the
oven
I'm gonna run it over here I'm gonna
flip it out as fast and as safe as
possible so it's gonna be hot it's gonna
be big there won't be any time to spare
these are gonna get pretty intense I
might be in full crazy Alvin mode so if
I don't say anything that's because the
focus it'll make the food look good I'm
pretty nervous for it so here we go oh
all right well this table is really
smooth this is looking pretty cool
all right here we go our low water bath
Oh so let's get this
I hear that's there you gotta get under
it
good grip here we go guys
this one's for all the money's oh holy
[ __ ]
[Music]
holy moly has got to go back all my time
so we can get it on to the other train
all righty
Wow you got this whoo whoa that's a dig
Luigi take right there oh my god I love
it so much
all right I got I got some parchment
because I'm gonna do some powdered sugar
make it rain as we usually do this so
cool I'm so happy hit with hurt I think
this is it we did it
this is particularly Japanese cheesecake
look at that hey I want to stop doing
them ruin this whole thing so let's go
surprise Jasmine yeah hungry yeah
awesome jiggly cheesecake yeah well here
you go
I have a regular one this is this is a
normal sized one this Reverend I want
you to look good
take it in so please close your eyes
okay when I count to three I want you to
open your eyes and see the cheesecake
okay one two three
good value like it's beautiful yeah I
think you're like you're a your God
oh thanks homie you want this thing yes
all right let's get in here how about
you cut himself a bigger slice just
saying hey they're not you oh my god
well I'll give the bigger one to you
thank you all right well here you go oh
all right well here's your piece thank
you please eat while it is still warm
yeah how do you feel on the receiving
end I'm quitting my show don't say that
have you gone down to the cross section
yet no well I'll give you see here right
a little more like a custard flan kind
of action mm-hmm going on so you get
more textures mmm
well I'm glad you liked it thanks for
coming on the show I'm glad to people
that love giant food finally got to hang
out and eat a giant food together so
this has been great curve Cheers hmm Oh
God well we're doing it
I mean jiggly she's gay I don't do go
not have to wiggle very happy and the
way it turned out
almost blacked out in a certain point
but I'm glad I got Alexis to come in and
pull through Jasmine seemed pretty happy
about it and I was just so excited to
see her face and her reaction to it
because she loves giant food just as
much as I do if you have any guesses to
what I'll be making next any comments
any suggestions you know any ideas that
you think you want me to make it to a
giant reality feel free to leave a
comment below a 70 Instagram message
I'll see what I can do but you know
until next time
[Music]
[Music]
you